matic éthique et chic rien de plus
angoissant avec les mecs comme ça a dit
kathy gatti pas y aller mais qu'il
fallait pas laisser bras tu la gardes
quand il arrivait dans l'émission était
comment may be est ce que vous vous avez
peut-être un signe distinctif voilà ce
qu'on pouvait faire à nos
téléspectateurs et en bons noté le truc
qu'ils préfèrent voilà vous quand vous
arrivez dans une émission chemin tant
que ce soit et comme la gaffe qui est un
truc il s'adonne à l'egypte benjamin
castaldi gaza kamal habib aller acheter
ce test
au rang des pays bas la bonne note lors
du repas des lemmings match et catchy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah non mais attendez ya rien de plus
angoissant avec les banques elles mêmes
motifs hausse a atteint 4 et gatti pas y
aller mais qui veut parler ces pratiques
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dont michel mr a les bases une culbute
aussi des gens compétents attendus à
lille
[Applaudissements]
je peux crier non il a mis dessus
cependant on n'est plus dans ce délire
la mêlée c'est là qu'on a quand même non
non accord d'accord je sens que je vais
avoir de bambi de manière décalée
catalan ou alors vous ça va être intense
sur allan là retour en arrière
ce soir c'est mana mana à lakota
c'était quoi c'est panama l'un et
l'autre qui dit elle a rien compris
paname pas d'âme on arrivé là tu as et
battu n'importe quoi et en fait moi
c'est un hommage au pays basque
vous allez voir bah je me sens pas du
tout je suis sûr que ça va être le plus
triste de tous sinon si c'est bien
possible et sais pas où je vous fait
sentir
attention je compte sur vous ouais bon
papa papa papa et ben voila merci ma
publication dresse sur la vie de ma mère
je dois tu chéris aux armes citoyens
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bordeaux 10 si rebecca voulait qu'on dit
c'est ça non aux armes aux armes c'est
géraldine maillet c'est géraldine
maillet on va tout ce beau monde unique
est à longueuil
ouais alors vous suivez un invitation
avec kenny des idées 2
j'ai ma gueule tu as bien fait sur le
prime oui mais on arrive l optimisation
du travail
c'est pas mal c'est efficace et slogan
tu t'es tu
[Musique]